Let me share with you something I found particularly
weird when I was a student first learning
calculus.
Let’s say you have a circle with radius
5 centered at the origin of the xy-coordinate
plane, which is defined using the equation
x^2 + y^2 = 5^2. That is, all points on this
circle are a distance 5 from the origin, as
encapsulated by the pythagorean theorem with
the sum of the squares of the legs of this
triangle equalling the square of the hypotenuse,
52.
And suppose you want to find the slope of
a tangent line to this circle, maybe at the
point (x, y) = (3, 4).
Now, if you’re savvy with geometry, you
might already know that this tangent line
is perpendicular to the radius line touching
that point. But let’s say you don’t already
know that, or that you want a technique that
generalizes to curves other than circles.
As with other problems about slope of tangent
lines, they key thought here is to zoom in
close enough that the curve basically looks
just like its own tangent line, then ask about
a tiny step along that curve.
The y-component of that little step is what
you might call dy, and the x-component is
a little dx, so the slope we’re looking
for is the rise over run dy/dx.
But unlike other tangent-slope problems in
calculus, this curve is not the graph of a
function, so we cannot take a simple derivative,
asking about the size of a tiny nudge to the
output of a function caused by some tiny nudge
to the input. x is not an input and y is not
an output in this case, they’re both just
interdependent values related by some equation.
This is called an “implicit curve”; it’s
just the set of all points (x, y) that satisfy
some property written in terms of the two
variables x and y.
The procedure for finding dy/dx here is what
I found very weird as a calculus student,
you take the derivative of both sides of this
equation like this: For the derivative of
x2 you write 2x*dx, similarly y2 becomes 2y*dy,
and the derivative of the constant 52 on the
right is 0.
You can see why this feels strange, right?
What does it mean to take a derivative of
an expression with multiple variables? And
why are we tacking on the little dy and dx
in this way?
But if you just blindly move forward with
what you get here, you can rearrange to find
an expression for dy/dx, which in this case
comes out to -x/y.
So at a point with coordinates (x, y) = (3,
4), that slope would be -¾, evidently.
This strange process is called “implicit
differentiation”. Don’t worry, I have
an explanation for how you can interpret taking
a derivative of an expression with two variables
like this.
But first, I want to set aside this particular
problem, and show how this is related to a
different type of calculus problem: Related
rates.
Imagine a 5 meter long ladder up against a
wall, where the top of the ladder starts of
4 meters above the ground, which, by the pythagorean
theorem, means the bottom is 3 meters away
from the wall.
And say it’s slipping down the wall in such
a way that the top of the ladder is dropping
at 1 meter per second.
The question is, in that initial moment, what
is the rate at which the bottom of the ladder
is moving away from the wall.
It’s interesting, right? That distance from
the bottom of the ladder to the wall is 100%
determined by the distance between the top
of the ladder and the floor, so we should
have enough information to figure out how
the rates of change for each value depend
on each other, but it might not be entirely
clear at first how to relate the two.
First thing’s first, it’s always nice
to give names to the quantities we care about.
So label the distance from the top of the
ladder to the ground y(t), written as a function
of time because it’s changing. Likewise,
label the distance between the bottom of the
ladder and the wall x(t).
They key equation here that relates these
terms is the pythagorean theorem: x(t)2 +
y(t)2 = 52. What makes this equation powerful
is that it’s true at all points in time.
One way to solve this would be to isolate
x(t), figure out what what y(t) must be based
this 1 meter/second drop rate, then take a
derivative of the resulting function; dx/dt,
the rate at which x is changing with respect
to time.
And that’s fine; it involves a couple layers
of using the chain rule, and it will definitely
work for you. But I want to show a different
way to think about the same thing.
This left-hand side of the equation is a function
of time, right? It just so happens to equal
a constant, meaning this value evidently doesn’t
change while time passes, but it’s still
written as an expression dependent on time
which we can manipulate like any other function
with t as an input.
In particular, we can take a derivative of
the left hand side, which is a way of saying
“If I let a little bit of time pass, dt,
which causes y to slightly decrease, and x
to slightly increase, how much does this expression
change”.
On the one hand, we know that derivative should
be 0, since this expression equals a constant,
and constants don’t care about your tiny
nudge to time, they remain unchanged.
But on the other hand, what do you get by
computing the derivative of this left-hand-side?
The derivative of x(t)2 is 2*x(t)*(the derivative
of x). That’s the chain rule I talked about
last video. 2x*dx represents the size of a
change to x2 caused by a change to x, and
we’re dividing by dt.
Likewise, the rate at which y(t)2 is changing
is 2*y(t)*(the derivative of y).
Evidently, this whole expression must be zero,
which is equivalent to saying x2+y2 doesn’t
change while the ladder moves.
And at the very start, t=0, the height y(t)
is 4 meters, the distance x(t) is 3 meters,
and since the top of the ladder is dropping
at a rate of 1 meter per second, that derivative
dy/dt is -1 meters/second.
Now this gives us enough information to isolate
the derivative dx/dt, which, when you work
it out, is (4/3) meters per second.
Now compare this to the problem of finding
the slope of tangent line to the circle. In
both cases, we had the equation x2 + y2 = 52,
and in both cases we ended up taking the derivative
of each side of this expression.
But for the ladder problem, these expressions
were functions of time, so taking the derivative
has a clear meaning: it’s the rate at which
this expression changes as time change.
But what makes the circle situation strange
is that rather than saying a small amount
of time dt has passed, which causes x and
y to change, the derivative has the tiny nudges
dx and dy both just floating free, not tied
to some other common variable like time.
Let me show you how you can think about this:
Give this expression x2 + y2 a name, maybe
S.
S is essentially a function of two variables,
it takes every point (x, y) on the plane and
associates it with a number.
For points on this circle, that number is
25. If you step off that circle away from
the center, that value would be bigger. For
other points (x, y) closer to the origin,
that value is smaller.
What it means to take a derivative of this
expression, a derivative of S, is to consider
a tiny change to both these variables, some
tiny change dx to x, and some tiny change
dy to y –and not necessarily one that keeps
you on this circle, by the way, it’s just
some tiny step in any direction on the xy-plane–
and ask how much the value of S changes. That
difference in the value of S, from the original
point to the nudged point, is what I’m writing
as “dS”.
For example, in this picture we’re starting
at a point where x is 3 and y is 4, and let’s
just say that step dx is... -0.02, and that
dy is -0.01. Then the decrease to S, the amount
the x2+y2 changes over that step, will be
around 2(3)(-0.02) + 2(4)(-0.01). That’s
what this derivative expression 2x*dx + 2y*dy
means, it tells you how much the value x2+y2
changes, as determined by the point (x, y)
where you started, and the tiny step (dx,
dy) that you take.
As with all things derivative, this is only
an approximation, but it gets more and more
true for smaller and smaller choices of dx
and dy.
The key point is that when you restrict yourself
to steps along this circle, you’re essentially
saying you want to ensure that this value
S doesn’t change; it starts at a value of
25, and you want to keep it at a value of
25; that is, dS should be 0.
So setting this expression 2x*dx + 2y*dy equal
to 0 is the condition under which a tiny step
stays on the circle.
Again, this is only an approximation. Speaking
more precisely, that condition keeps you on
a tangent line of the circle, not the circle
itself, but for tiny enough steps those are
essentially the same thing.
Of course, there’s nothing special about
the expression x2+y2 = 52 here. You could
have some other expression involving x’s
and y’s, representing some other curve,
and taking the derivative of both sides like
this would give you a way to relate dx to
dy for tiny steps along that curve.
It’s always nice to think through more examples,
so consider the expression sin(x)*y2 = x,
which corresponds to many U-shaped curves
on the plane. Those curves represent all the
points (x, y) of the plane where the value
of sin(x)*y2 equals the value of x.
Now imagine taking some tiny step with components
(dx, dy), and not necessarily one that keeps
you on the curve. Taking the derivative of
each side of this equation will tell us how
much the value of that side changes during
this step.
On the left side, the product rule that we
found in the last video tells us that this
should be “left d-right plus right d-left”:
sin(x)*(the change to y2), which is 2y*dy,
plus y2*(the change to sin(x)), which is cos(x)*dx.
The right side is simply x, so the size of
a change to the value is exactly dx, right?
Setting these two sides equal to each other
is a way of saying “whatever your tiny step
with coordinates (dx, dy) is, if it’s going
to keep us on this curve, the values of both
the left-hand side and the right-hand side
must change by the same amount.” That’s
the only way this top equation can remain
true.
From there, depending on what problem you’re
solving, you could manipulate further with
algebra, where perhaps the most common goal
is to find dy divided by dx.
As one more example, let me show how you can
use this technique to help find new derivative
formulas.
I’ve mentioned in a footnote video that
the derivative of ex is itself, but what about
the derivative of its inverse function the
natural log of x?
The graph of ln(x) can be thought of as an
implicit curve; all the points on the xy plane
where y = ln(x), it just happens to be the
case that the x’s and y’s of this equation
aren’t as intermingled as they were in other
examples.
The slope of this graph, dy/dx, should be
the derivative of ln(x), right?
Well, to find that, first rearrange this equation
y = ln(x) to be ey = x. This is exactly what
the natural log of x means; it’s saying
e to the what equals x.
Since we know the derivative of ey, we can
take the derivative of both sides, effectively
asking how a tiny step with components (dx,
dy) changes the value of each side.
To ensure the step stays on the curve, the
change to the left side of the equation, which
is ey*dy, must equals the change to the right
side, which is dx.
Rearranging, this means dy/dx, the slope of
our graph, equals 1/ey. And when we’re on
this curve, ey is by definition the same as
x, so evidently the slope is 1/x.
An expression for the slope of the graph of
function in terms of x like this is the derivative
of that function, so evidently the derivative
of ln(x) is 1/x.
By the way, all of this is a little peek into
multivariable calculus, where you consider
functions with multiple inputs, and how they
change as you tweak those inputs.
The key, as always, is to have a clear image
in your head of what tiny nudges are at play,
and how exactly they depend on each other.
Next up, I’ll talk about about what exactly
a limit is, and how it’s used to formalize
the idea of a derivative.